showing you got so much going on tonight
you're performing special performances
you know collaborations nominations it's
all happening this year for you it is
all happening it feels good man I feel
like actually it's just so excited right
now I'm like giddy I feel giddy I've
never felt like this on a carpet before
yeah I know the song meant so much to
you we spoke about it and this is a
really important album in terms of your
transition is an artist so to be you
know recognized by the Grammys you could
win tonight your first that's true yeah
I mean and also in my blood being
recognized as just nomination is means
the absolute world to me there's no song
that I'd rather be recognized so like I
said I'm just honestly just overwhelmed
with exciting right now sure what's this
room right here about you and Miley
Cyrus committing this creative
relationship to more than just the stage
I guess we'll have to just wait and see
that's the worst poker face I've ever
seen I know I never set out a good poker
face man and I never will what is it
about you two you know when it comes to
singing together because you're a part
of you know that the Dolly Parton should
meet the other night you know tonight
she just lets it all out you know like
she doesn't hold anything back and it's
fully music you can see like there's
this thing that happens you start
singing her highs switch over and she's
just like in bliss and when you sing
with someone who does that you also fall
into it and it's just a dream to sing
with her before she was a singer a
hundred percent and just that's a person
just to stop caring what people think
and start enjoying what I do for a
living and start loving music more than
I ever had is that we right now because
you know you're pretty open on the
record about some of the things you went
through and know to get those songs out
we're wet now at this point your life
I'm at a place where I feel like there's
no way that you can make somebody feel
good if you don't feel good yourself
that's right it starts with you and
that's a very very important thing so
who are you gonna call when you win
tonight Sean they're all here my mom and
dad are here and
no man I just yeah like I said I'm
overwhelmed this has been this is really
different today for me so I'm great to
see you good luck tonight man
[Music]